hey guys it is the last day of the month
where we get to celebrate the new year
and the day right before the month where
those of us who are single get reminded
how single we are yay that's 2 News
first up I have a lot of Nintendo ish
nice roll through so let's get you
caught up Nintendo has confirmed to
gamespot that we year production has
ended globally which is disappointing
news for me and the other 14 people who
bought we use in actuality as of
December 31 of last year the console
sold 13.56 million units worldwide
Nintendo also reported their earnings
and hardware sales today which revealed
that while the Wii U has taken a 75
percent decrease hit in sales in the
last nine months of 2016 compared to the
year before 3d hardware sales are up ten
percent in fact the nifty little
handheld sold almost six and a half
million units in just the last nine
months or 2016 which is huge the 3d ice
is now sold a total of sixty 5.3 million
units to date overall Nintendo reported
a substantial profit for the company in
2016 on the gaming side Animal Crossing
for mobile has been delayed until the
next financial year so it could arrive
anytime between this April to next March
Nintendo say the reason for the delay is
to accommodate both Fire Emblem heroes
and Super Mario run Animal Crossing for
mobile is no stranger to delays as it
was originally slated to arrive in 2016
finally Super Mario run has reached a
whopping 78 million downloads from which
five percent of users have paid the ten
dollars to unlock all the content
meaning the game has brought in at least
39 million dollars in revenue minus
apples cut of course next up Resident
Evil sevens first DLC has arrived on ps4
the band footage vol 1 content comes
with two scenarios and a boat called
Ethan must die the first of the two
scenarios bedroom sees you trying to
escape from a locked room while the
second called nightmare will have you
fending off waves of enemies until
morning the tough-as-nails ethan must
die mode is separate from the tapes and
story of the main guy
and is not support PSV are bandaged
vol.1 is out now on ps4 as part of the
third jealousies and pass or is a
standalone download for 10 bucks and
will be available on xbox one and pc on
februari 21 and footage volume 2 is qu
out on Valentine's Day or februari 14
finally Square Enix has dropped some
final fantasy release dates the
publisher announced today that the HD
remaster of final fantasy 12 will launch
exclusively for the ps4 on July 11 final
fantasy 12 the zodiac age will
reportedly feature better looking
backgrounds character models and
cutscenes an autosave feature reduced
loading times Japanese and English
voices as well as the option to use the
original or rerecorded score turbo mode
is also being improved and there will
now be support for 7.1 surround sound
square also announced the release dates
for Final Fantasy 15th upcoming
expansion packs the Final Fantasy 15
booster pack will launch on februari 21
and will give you quote an exhilarating
experience in battles presumably via the
expansions Power Rangers esque magitek
exosuits much 28 will see the release of
episode clario which fittingly allows
you to play as latio episodes for other
party members ignis and prompt dough as
well as the comrade expansion that will
add 4 player co-op featuring the four
main characters are due out later though
no date has been officially announced
all the Final Fantasy 15 sdlc is
included in the $25 season parks on xbox
one and ps4 that is it from me today to
head to gamespot for our livestream
replay of rosy sevens first DLC and a
look at design of tooth crack in the
slab level I will see you again tomorrow
you